hello and welcome to this video this
Vincent Vega my opponent sudden new
account I don't remember playing him
[Music]
okay so let's see it's a fairly new
account see what he does with this v5
business yeah recently I got hammered
there is no bond pretty badly I forgot
forgot some line so we'll see what
Vincent is doing now quite often white
takes on f 6m this one ok interesting I
don't really remember what I'm doing
here I think just before 1 i'm not
mistaken but sometimes i get my own
analysis there yeah you know after
before it's not so easy for y now to
make a move as 92 here i can go Quinn d6
I remember this one it looks quite
strange but it is fairly ok yeah six is
ok I believe 1 94 and 96 I don't
remember
hmm taking is clearly wrong okay i think
it was mighty form i don't remember i
don't recall it that some pizza game
world song it's not the title so he's
probably going to move his bishop and
then I want to go with six
we move that name well maybe I can take
I mean this whole business is of course
them kind of risky anyway it is entirely
non-symmetrical and therefore yeah
interesting in order to fight for you
have to fight for the full point but it
is definitely not easy to handle on Kim
let's do this put more pressure on d5 if
he would be forced he isn't that
difficult be forced to take on these six
I'd be definitely very okay something
like d 621 king d 1 d 6 i would be quite
happy with the space gain on the
queenside would be very useful the thing
is i wonder if you can yeah this is the
kind of move that I was expecting I can
take a five now on next move I think I'm
taking it now first of all 94 d take the
form should be fine then my bishop is
covering the Queen on the sixth okay
he's going for that interesting I was
thinking I should confine him now that
comes with the temple also okay what's
going on
the Queen has a quite decent spot on his
six so maybe just Bishop e7 he probably
won't trade some go here and now just
yeah continue to develop I just wonder
how exactly 96 is a six that's a bit a
bit odd bit annoying okay come on Castle
first maybe I should play like d6d 697
and on a six always have Bishop to c6
something like that and also I mean he
has Musa as well so something to react
to you ever think i'm going to to do
this it feels fairly okay if I've is
also not a bad spot for the night at 595
maybe there is also bishop at 635 but
that is also quite quite useful looking
Knight a5 okay i can drop back to a
eight this could not be seven huh that
could be an idea might be an idea okay
well no
thinking t5 but that isn't such a great
solution either
d 597 irritates me quite heavily maybe
this one look the seven and md5 covering
stuff and still preparing defile not
easy to play the night on 85 didn't
really look all that dangerous at first
but it is a point yeah not jumping in to
be seven so I've got two looks now
centralized I wondered if I should go
Bishop f6 and should have six now as
soon as prevented okay I try this now
get the bishop to e5 get this created
right also threatening bishops III here
willing to the exchange not eating and
active afraid of that not sure that was
really something to be afraid of can I
go d5 I think I will I mean he doesn't
have all that much time I didn't think
about them okay hi morning just very
active shoot them for trade a couple of
times yeah but it's not so clear I can
could have gone quindi one as well yeah
probably the time will ultimately can
tell here turn yeah we know the time is
part of the game it cost me dearly old
enough like 40 that's what it is um
pretty tough them pretty tough let's
gets the check it out I mean I think why
did not have enough compensation down
the whole own construction II of this
is really strange I understand but this
is something analyzed I think like it's
okay here the good thing about such a
position is it's a position where as a
stronger player you have really have
chances to get something substantial out
of the opening because you can really
make serious mistake save you if you
don't know it correctly all or don't
understand the position correctly it
happens with both sides of quality you
can also lose badly but it's like it's
not the slovaks change so I jumped into
your form we should drop back yeah yeah
queen age six or seven engine suggestion
this idea is fairly well-known the idea
is to push 25 and dr. Bishop d3 night
takes 23 white is forced to take with
the app porn this is certainly playable
might be each was given by the engines
this kind of kind of position if it's
okay for black hair like is happy to
have traded the Queen and the minor
piece and the Queen study already has a
bit of a space advantage like it's not
better but is fine certainly possible
yeah Queen ds3 this looks a little bit
more dangerous for sure if I'm taking
his recapturing and now my night has
been on its own and so probably six is
incorrect here in this position III
Bishop e7 now everything looks kind of
okay I'm thinking I into T really took
no he gave this pawn it's clear that
something like that as I mentioned
during the game is entirely on promising
I've got more space is king as a bit of
them so yeah should be three years
another way to second point I don't
quite believe in this here should be
very okay
yeah computer gives me a substantial
advantage maybe I had some other way of
playing in the game it didn't feel so
clear to me so I engine always goes a
six yeah maybe this is correct just stop
the upon and never felt it was worth
investing this temple that the engine is
as totally correct them and this most of
all that clear as confirmed by the
computer it doesn't give such an high
email I mean I'm okay but I'm not
substantially better anymore so be three
age five Jim yeah I think this has
helped me I have meant it's confirmed by
the computer he has to do something else
yeah I was only sure that there must be
something else who kept one cannot be
the way to put problems might be 70 okay
so the engine gives this area which we
will be the spawn f3 yeah okay well this
is very okay right yeah I'm very okay
even if i'm giving a point back that's a
very good structure ok i will she having
I'm fine and I'm definitely fun our
politics I didn't think of that at all
that's a good idea really ha you know
what's a good at it because I'm click on
the deef I'm or something like this for
example a standing gives is also fairly
nice the night is in no position to
attack my pawns it's simple it's
important interesting
okay i just took with the Queen
routinely thinking that I've got t5
anyway but when this kind of situation
isn't that easy come here I wasn't sure
if I'm winning i mean the bishop on c4
is quite strong okay I mostly just
continue teacher to win on time I mean I
knew that I was winning on time I was
looking all that hard some surprise that
this is a troll okay can enter you can
enter check this is saying okay yeah
okay then again I didn't try all that
hard knowing that I would be no on time
anyway tough game but it is an
interesting line of an interesting open
line to get a fight going ok guys thanks
for watching